Atomwaffen sind wohl die schrecklichsten Waffen,
die in den Arsenalen von verschiedenen
Armeen vorhanden sind - ob ihrer enormen Zerstörungs-
wirkung. Genau diese Zerstörungswirkung hat zur
Folge, dass sie in erster Linie als Abschreckungswaffen
verwendet werden. Es besteht trotzdem auch
die Möglichkeit, dass diese nach wie vor auch
zum Einsatz kommen und ihre schreckliche Wirkung
an einem Gefechtsfeld oder einem Kriegsschauplatz
entsprechend entfalten. Mein Name ist Jürgen
Schlechter. Ich bin der Kommandant des ABC-
Abwehrzentrums des Österreichischen Bundesheeres
und möchte mit Ihnen gemeinsam die wesentlichen
Fakten und Einsatzarten von Atomwaffen besprechen.
Insgesamt gibt es weltweit noch über 10.000
Atomsprengköpfe und Atomwaffen, die eingesetzt
werden können. Die Masse von diesen Atomwaffen
wird durch die Atomwaffen-Besitzstaaten
der Vereinigten Staaten von Amerika und der
Russischen Föderation in Besitz gehalten, wobei es
mittlerweile auch mehrere andere kleine Staaten
gibt, die über Atomwaffen-Technologie und auch
Atomwaffen besitzen und verfügen. Eine Atomwaffe
basiert auf einer sehr simplen Basistechnologie.
Eine Atomwaffe aber entsprechend einsatzbereit
zu halten, ist eine große Ingenieurskunst und
erfordert ein großes Maß an technologischem und
produktiven Know-how. Zunächst die Basistechnologie:
Die ist denkbar einfach. Man schießt ein Neutron auf
einen Urankern. Diese Energie ist so groß, dass
der Urankern in mehrere Bestandteile zerfällt
und unter anderem auch wiederum in drei weitere
Neutronen. Diese Neutronen schießen wiederum
auf andere Urankerne und zerstören diese und
dadurch wird eine sogenannte Kettenreaktion
in Gang gesetzt. Bei dieser Kettenreaktion
entsteht in erster Linie sehr viel Druck und
sehr viel Hitze. Um das ein bisschen in einen
Maßstab setzen zu können: Wenn wir ein Gramm Uran
spalten, dann setzt das so viel
Hitze frei wie etwa 2.500 Kilogramm Steinkohle
oder 2.000 Liter Heizöl oder 7 Stunden
lang eines großen Windrades hier an Energie
zu produzieren. Und diese Gesamtenergie, dieanfällt,
beträgt zu 90% Hitze und zu etwa 10%
radioaktive Strahlung. Wie wird nun dieses Basisprinzip
bei einer Atomwaffe zum Einsatz gebracht?
Zunächst braucht man für die Kettenreaktion auch
eine sogenannte kritische Masse an Uranerz. Diese
kritische Masse ist andererseits aber wieder sehr
labil und kann selbstständig zu einer Umsetzung
und Detonation kommen. Daher muss man, um dieses
Uran entsprechend in einer Waffe transport- und
lagerungsfähig zu halten, muss man diese kritische
Masse zunächst in zwei Teile zerlegen. Wir sehen
das hier auf der Grafik: Wir haben einen größeren
gelben Teil und einen kleineren gelten Teil. Wenn
die Atombombe zur Detonation kommt, dann wird der
kleinere gelbe Teil in den größeren gelben Teil
hineingeschossen. Es entsteht dann diese kritische
Masse. Gleichzeitig werden in einem milliardstel
bis millionstel Sekundenbruchteil die Neutronen
auf die Urankerne geschossen und es kommt eben zur
Initiierung der Kettenreaktion und diese Atombombe
wird dann entsprechend ihre Wirkung tätigen.
Die moderneren Generationen von Atomwaffen
sind mittlerweile Inklusionswaffen. Hier ist die
kritische Masse nicht unter Druck zusammengestellt
sondern hat viel mehr Platz, sich auszudehnen. Wir
sehen dass hier blau dargestellt und dafür sind
am Rande der Bombe Sprengladungen angebracht
und durch die erste Detonation wird die kritische
Masse zusammengedrückt und erreicht eben dann
diesen hohen Grad an Instabilität, die es erfordert
damit dann die Neutronen die Kettenreaktion
auslösen können und die Technologie, die
dahinter erforderlich ist, ist eben eine sehr
komplexe und hochtechnologische und daher können
eben noch nicht alle Staaten der Welt, obwohl die
BBasistechnologie eine sehr einfache ist, entsprechend
Atomwaffen produzieren und diese auch unterhalten.
Nach dem Einsatz einer Atombombe haben wir
mehrere Phänomene, die wir auch aus weiterer
Entfernung entsprechend beobachten können. Zunächst
entsteht wie bei jeder Detonation ein sehr großer
Lichtblitz, ein Feuerball und eine sehr, sehr hohe
radioaktive Anfangsstrahlung. Kurze zeit darauf
entwickelt sich die Druck- und die Hitzewelle,
die den Großteil der Schäden an Infrastruktur und
an Lebewesen auf unserer Erde verursachen. Danach,
aufgrund der Thermik und der hohen Temperaturen,
wird der Feuerball aufsteigen und wird sich diese
mittlerweile sehr bekannte Atompilzwolke
entwickeln, die dann am Ende unter einer maximalen
Ausbreitung mehrere Kilometer hoch sein kann
und entsprechend groß und deutlich sichtbar ist.
Dabei sind mehrere Faktoren beeinflussend, um
auch feststellen zu können, um welche Art und um
welches Ausmaß einer Atomwaffen-Detonation es sich
handelt. Zunächsteinmal ist der Detonationspunkt
wichtig. Ist der Detonationspunkt auf der Erde oder
ist der Detonationspunkt in einer hohen Lufthöhe?
Ich werde das noch später erklären, weil das
unterschiedliche Auswirkungen auf das Schadensbild
hat und dann entsteht eben dieser dieser Atompilz,
auf den von verschiedenen Perimetern, wie etwa einer
Wolkenuntergrenze und -obergrenze und einem
Nullpunkt, die Spezialisten des Bundesheeres
ermitteln können, um welche Art von einer
Atombombe es sich gehandelt hat. Die Schadens-
radien sind, wie ich schon eingangs gesagt habe,
entsprechend sehr, sehr hoch und übertreffen alles,
was wir an bisherigen konventionellen Waffen-
wirkungen kennen. Wenn wir das Beispiel hernehmen
einer Atombombe, die in etwa das Kaliber der
Bombe hat, die nach dem 2. Weltkrieg oder zum
Ende des 2. Weltkrieges in Hiroshima gezündet
worden ist, dann entspricht das in etwa einer
sogenannten 10-Kilotonnen-Bombe. Hier hat allein
der Feuerball einen Radius von 120 Metern.
Die Anfangsstrahlung in einer Dosis, wo man vermutlich
nicht überleben wird, beträgt 1,2 Kilometer.
Die Hitzestrahlung und auch die Druckwelle werden in
etwa 1,4 und die Druckschäden bis 2,5 Kilometer
Radius erreichen. Also Ausmaße der Zerstörung,
die mit herkömmlichen Waffen kaum möglich sind.
Ausschlaggebend für die Wirkung auf der Erde
für eine Atombombe ist die Art und Weise,
wo sie zur Detonation kommt - der sogenannte
Detonationspunkt. Die erste Möglichkeit ist,
dass die Atombombe auf der Erdoberfläche auftritt
und eine sogenannte Bodendetonation stattfindet.
Die Bodendetonation erkennen wir hier an dem
Bild sehr eindeutig, weil die gesamte Wolke
und der Pilz entsprechend dunkel gefärbt sind. Das
entsteht dadurch, dass eben durch die Detonation
am Erdboden auch Erdmaterial aufgeschüttet wird
und entsprechend in die Luft geschleudert wird
und mit dieser Wolke und dem Pilz mitentsteht.
Das ist auch der Ausgangspunkt
für den späteren, für uns im Nachgang einer Atom-
detonation so gefährlichen radioaktiven Fall-out.
Im Gegensatz dazu gibt es eine niedrige Luft-
detonation. Das ist auch die Detonationsart
und der Detonationspunkt wie die Atombombe
in Hiroshima gezündet wird.
Diese wird in einigen Kilometern Höhe gezündet und
es entsteht ein Atompilz, der keine dunkle
Färbung aufzeichnet, weil hier kaum Erdmaterial
entsprechend aufgewirbelt werden konnte. Dafür ist
sowohl die radioaktive Wirkung als auch die
Druck- und Hitzewelle von oben kegelförmig herab
auf den Erdboden und erreicht hier ein höchstes
Maß an Zerstörung von menschlichem und tierischem
Leben auf unserem Planeten. Die dritte Detonation
ist die sogenannte hohe Luftdetonation. Diese ist
in mehreren 10 Kilometern Höhe und wie manhier
sieht, ist auch der entsprechende Atompilz
kaum noch wahrnehmbar. Die Auswirkung auf die
Lebewesen mit der Primärstrahlung oder auch der
Druckwelle ist nur marginal, dafür entsteht hier
als Hauptwirkung ein Nebeneffekt: der sogenannte
nukleare elektromagnetische Impuls. Das ist eine
Energie-Freisetzung ähnlich einem Blitzschlag mit
der vielfachen Energie eines Blitzschlages und
auch mit der mehrfachen Geschwindigkeit eines
Blitzschlages - mit dem Ergebnis, dass elektrische
Anlagen und IKT-Anlagen, die wir auf der Erde
benützen, entsprechend schnell außer Gefecht
gesetzt und beschädigt werden können und die
herkömmlichen Schutzeinrichtungen nicht mehr
greifen können, weil sie zu langsam reagieren.
Wir kategorisieren Nuklearwaffen hinsichtlich ihrer
Einsatzart, ihres Einsatzzweckes und ihrer Technik.
Beginnend bei der Technik: Wir haben schon
gesprochen über die Kernspaltungswaffen.
Es gibt auch eine, vor allem im Bereich der
strategischen Atomwaffen, der Abschreckungs-
waffen, gibt es dann auch die Technologie der
Kernverschmelzung, wo noch ein größerer
Grad an Energie-Freisetzung und eine größere
Menge erreicht werden kann. Die Einsatzarten
haben wir schon besprochen: Es gibt eben die
Bodendetonation und es gibt die niedrige und die hohe
Luftdetonation. Und hinsichtlich des Einsatz-
zweckes werden Atomwaffen in sowohl taktische als
auch strategische Atomwaffen unterschieden. Die
taktischen Atomwaffen haben eher ein geringeres
Kaliber, also einen Detonationswert bis in etwa
200 Kilotonnen, und werden auf Trägerraketen-
systemen aufgebaut, die in etwa bis 5.000/5.500
Kilometer Reichweite reichen. Das besondere an
diesen taktischen Atomwaffen ist, dass sie eben
auf einem Gefechtsfeld eingesetzt werden können
und dort zum Erreichen einer Entscheidung,
die auf konventionellem Wege nicht möglich ist,
eingesetzt werden können. Im Gegensatz dazu
haben wir die strategischen Atomwaffen, die einen
weit höheren Detonationswert haben und auch auf
Trägersystemen aufgesetzt sind und verschossen
werden. Die eine weitaus größere Reichweite haben -
die Interkontinentalraketen, wie sie oft genannt
werden. Diese Atomwaffen haben derartig großes
Schadenspotenzial, dass deren Hauptaufgabe die
Abschreckung ist. Wenn wir diese Atomwaffen,
die strategischen, zum Einsatz bringen würden,
dann würden auch Automatismen bei den jeweils
anderen kriegführenden Konfliktparteien in
Kraft treten und diese Atomwaffen haben
das Potenzial, unseren Erdball mehrfach
komplett auszulöschen, so dass kein Leben
auf diesem Planeten Erde mehr überbleibt.
Die Wirkung einer Atombombe auf uns Menschen
ist vielfach und jede einzelne davon würde
ausreichen, um menschliches Leben in wenigen
Momenten auszulöschen. Wir haben einmal zunächst
die thermische Strahlung, die Hitzewelle, die
wohl auch für die größte Zerstörungswirkung
an Menschen und Lebewesen verantwortlich ist.
Wir haben aber auch die Kernstrahlung, wenn
ich mich also im Nahbereich einerAtombombe
nach einer Detonation befinde und
mich nicht ausreichend schützen konnte, dann
ist die Strahlung derartig intensiv, dass die
Zellstruktur, die DNA, entsprechend massiv
geschädigt wird und Lebewesen binnen weniger
Tage verenden beziehungsweise sterben. Eine
weitere Folgeerscheinung der Hitzewelle ist
die Druckwelle. Diese zerstört Infrastruktur wie
Gebäude, Häuser, Straßen und Stromversorgungen.
Und die vierte Wirkungsweise ist eben der
sogenannte nukleare elektromagnetische Impuls,
der besonders auf elektrische und elektronische
Anlagen abzielt. Hier, an den Fotos, die alle
im Zuge des Atombombenabwurfs von Hiroshima
entstanden sind, sieht man an einigen ausgewählten
Beispielen, wie etwa hier, dass überall dort, wo die
Personen ungeschützt waren, dementsprechend
die Hitze zur Wirkung gekommen ist und es
hier zur enormen Hitzeschäden gekommen ist.
Das sind also Verbrennungen, die bei Verbrennungen
dritten Grades beginnen und dann entsprechend
noch weiter hinauf eskaliert sind. Zusammenfassend
möchte ich feststellen: Es gibt zwei große Arten
von Atomwaffen - nämlich strategische Atomwaffen,
die in erster Linie der Abschreckung dienen, und
die - wie wir alle hoffen - nie zum Einsatz kommen
werden. Es gibt taktische Atomwaffen, die auf
einem Gefechtsfeld eingesetzt werden können. Wenn
wir das jetzt vergleichen oder übertragen auf
den derzeitigen Konflikt in der Ukraine, dann
müssen wir auch feststellen, dass die Primär-
wirkungen beim Einsatz einer solchen taktischen
Atomwaffe in der Ukraine keine Auswirkungen
auf Österreich haben werden und dass die
Auswirkungen eines Fall-out bei einer ungünstigen
Wettersituation in Österreich noch spürbar
werden können, aber weniger drastisch ausfallen
werden, wie wir das 1986 beim Kernkraftwerks-
unfall in Tschernobyl erleben mussten.
Das war ein kurzer Überblick über Atomwaffen.
Ich bedanke mich für eure Aufmerksamkeit!